I DON'T KNOW HOW WHEN YOUR CHILD
GOES TO SCHOOL AND THE MATH
TEACHER IS GONE, I DON'T KNOW
HOW YOU'RE GOING TO HIDE THAT.
>> I WANT TO BRING IN GENERAL
DAVID PETRAEUS.
GENERAL, WHEN YOU SEE THESE
PICTURES, WHICH ARE PRETTY
EXTRAORDINARY OF JUST THE FEW
BELONGINGS THAT PEOPLE ARE
FLEEING RUSSIA WITH, WHAT SHOULD
VLADIMIR PUTIN BE TAKING
WATCHING ALL OF THESE FIGHTING
AGE RUSSIAN MEN FLEEING RUSSIA?
>> WELL, HE'S CLEARLY VERY, VERY
DESPERATE, BRIANNA, THE FACT
THAT THEY'RE CONDUCTING THIS
MOBILIZATION REFLECT AS DYNAMIC
ON THE BATTLEFIELD IN UKRAINE
THAT IS INESCAPABLE AND I THINK
IRREVERSIBLE.
IT IS THAT UKRAINE HAS DONE A
VASTLY BETTER JOB AT MOBILIZING
ITS COUNTRY FOR A WAR.
SO NOW A COUNTRY THAT'S ONE
THIRD THE SIZE OF RUSSIA HAS A
LARGER ARMY, IS MUCH BETTER
EQUIPPED THANKS TO THE U.S. AND
OTHER NATO COUNTRIES, THE U.S.
NOW OVER $15 BILLION OF ARMS AND
AMMUNITION HAS ORGANIZED THESE
FORCES AND NOW IT'S EMPLOYING
THEM VERY EFFECTIVELY, TAKING
BACK TERRITORY THAT RUSSIA
SEIZED SINCE 24 OF FEBRUARY AND
THREATENING TO DO IT AGAIN IN
THE EAST.
THERE'S ANOTHER CITY THAT'S
ABOUT TO BE ENCIRCLED FROM WHICH
THE RUSSIANS WILL HAVE TO
WITHDRAW.
THE RUSSIANS HAVE TAKEN HUGE
LOSSES, MANY MULTIPLES IN THE
SEVEN MONTHS OF THIS WAR
COMPARED TO A DECADE IN
AFGHANISTAN.
PUTIN IS UNABLE TO PROVIDE THE
NUMBER OF REPLACEMENTS.
THAT'S WHY HE'S TAKEN THIS QUITE
DESPERATE STEP, WHICH HE REALLY
DIDN'T WANT TO TAKE BECAUSE HE
KNEW THAT THERE WOULD BE
DEMONSTRATIONS, HE KNEW THERE
WOULD BE THIS KIND OF EXODUS
FROM THE COUNTRY OF MILITARY AGE
MALES FEARING THEY WOULD BE
CONSCRIPTED, EVEN IF THEY DON'T
MEET THE CRITERIA OF THIS
MOBILIZATION.
AS YOUR REPORTED NOTED THE
SHAMBOLIC WAY IN WHICH THIS
MOBILIZATION HAS BEEN CARRIED
OUT AND VERY HIGHLY CRITICIZED
BY RUSSIAN CITIZENS.
SO HE'S IN A VERY, VERY TOUGH
SPOT.
AND AGAIN, I DON'T THINK THAT
THE NUMBER THAT HE WILL GATHER
WITH THIS PARTICULAR
MOBILIZATION WILL RESULT IN
ADDING WELL-TRAINED, PHYSICALLY
FIT, QUALIFIED, COHERENT UNITS
THAT CAN WITHSTAND THE UKRAINIAN
OFFENSES THAT WILL GO ON.
MAYBE THEY CAN PLUG A HOLE HERE
OR THERE BUT IT APPEARS FAIRLY
INEVITABLE THAT THE UKRAINIANS
ARE GOING TO CONTINUE TO TAKE
BACK TERRITORY AND THEY COULD
TAKE ALL THE WAY BACK TO WHAT
BEGAN ON 24 FEBRUARY WHEN RUSSIA
LAUNCHED THIS UNPROVOKED
INVASION.
>> YOU THINK AND YOU'VE BEEN
SAYING SINCE FEBRUARY THAT
UKRAINE COULD RECLAIM TERRITORY
TAKEN BY RUSSIA.
SO YOU THINK THEY CAN HOLD THAT
AND TAKE BACK MORE.
HOW FAR DO YOU THINK THEY CAN
GO?
>> WELL, ASSUMING THAT WE
CONTINUE TO ARM AND QUIP AND
--
EQUIP AND FUND THEM AND KEEP IN
MIND THIS COULD BE A COLD WINTER
IN EUROPE WITH THE GAS FLOW
DISRUPTED AND SO FORTH, BUT
ASSUMING THAT WE CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT THEM AND I THINK WE
WILL, I BELIEVE WE SHOULD VERY
STRONGLY BELIEVE THAT, I THINK
THEY CAN CONTINUE TO TAKE
GROUND, THE WINTER IS NOT GOING
TO SLOW THE UKRAINIANS DOWN AS
MUCH AS INDIVIDUALS PREDICT.
THEY'RE ON THEIR OWN SOIL,
THEY'RE FIGHTING FOR THEIR OWN
SECURITY.
THIS IS THEIR WAR OF
INDEPENDENCE IF YOU WILL.
THEIR MORALE IS NOW SKY HIGH,
RUSSIAN MORALE IS VERY LOW AND
IF WE START TO SEE RUSSIAN UNITS
BEGIN TO CRUMBLE AND THEN
PERHAPS IN SOME AREAS EVEN
COLLAPSE, WHICH IS NOT OUT OF
THE QUESTION, I THINK YOU COULD
SEE UKRAINIAN FORCES ROLL THIS
ALL THE WAY BACK, AT LEAST TO
SOME OF.
MAJOR STRONGHOLDS, THE MAJOR
CITIES THAT RUSSIA WILL HAVE
TAKEN, WHICH WILL BE JUST AS
DIFFICULT FOR THE UKRAINIANS TO
TAKE AS THEY WERE FOR THE
RUSSIANS GIVEN THE CHALLENGES OF
URBAN COMBAT.
BUT OVER THE MONTHS AHEAD, THERE
IS GOING TO BE CONTINUED
MOMENTUM BY THE UKRAINIANS.
THE RUSSIANS WILL BE DESPERATE
TO TRY TO HOLD THAT BACK.
THAT'S THE REASON FOR THIS
MOBILIZATION.
THAT'S THE REASON FOR PUTIN'S
THREATS OF USE OF NUCLEAR
WEAPONS AND SO FORTH.
I DON'T THINK THAT IS GOING TO
HAPPEN, ALTHOUGH WE NEED TO BE
CONCERNED ABOUT IT AND OF COURSE
OUR U.S. NATIONAL SECURITY
ADVISER JAKE SULLIVAN HAS OPENLY
SAID THAT THE U.S. HAS CAN'TED
WITH RUSSIA ABOUT WHAT WOULD
RESULT FROM THE USE WHICH WOULD
ACTUALLY REVERSE THE SITUATION
ON THE BATTLEFIELD.
IT CAN'T CHANGE THIS TERRIBLE
DYNAMIC FOR PUTIN, WHICH IS THAT
UKRAINE HAS DONE VASTLY BETTER
AT ROO KRUTING, TRAINING,
EQUIPPING AND NOW EMPLOYEES
FORCES THAT RUSSIA HAS.
>> IT REALLY INTERESTING TO HARR
SAY THAT ESPECIALLY GIVEN WHAT
WE'VE HEARD FROM FORMER
PRESIDENT MEDVEDEV.
I WANT TO LOOK AT THESE
PIPELINES LOOKING LIKE SABOTAGE
WHERE YOU HAVE HOLES IN THEM IN
MULTIPLE LOCATIONS AND IT
APPEARS THAT SIGNS ARE POINTING
TOWARD RUSSIA, THOUGH RUSSIA
HASN'T CLAIMED RESPONSIBILITY
FOR THIS.
IS THAT WHAT YOU WOULD EXPECT?
AND WHAT MESSAGE, IF THIS IS
RUSSIA, ARE THEY TRYING TO SEND?
>> YES, I THINK PROBABLY THAT IS
THE CASE.
THEY HAVE THE TECHNICAL
EXPERTISE, THE KNOWLEDGE OF THE
PIPELINES, ALL THE REST OF THAT
CAPABILITY AND CLEARLY WHAT
THEY'RE TRYING TO DO, AGAIN, IS
TO FORCE EUROPE TO FORCE UKRAINE
TO SEEK SOME KIND OF NEGOTIATED
RESOLUTION.
NOW, I THINK THERE WILL BE A
NEGOTIATED RESOLUTION AT SOME
TIME.
PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY HAS SAID
THIS IS HOW THIS WILL ULTIMATELY
END.
THE QUESTION IS WHERE WILL
UKRAINE AND RUSSIA BE ON THAT
BATTLEFIELD WHEN THE TIMES COMES
FOR THAT.
I WILL ALSO NOTE HERE THAT I
THINK WE NEED TO BE THINKING
AHEAD TO THAT MOMENT.
AGAIN, MANY, MANY MONTHS,
PERHAPS LONGER FROM THAT
PARTICULAR POINT.
BUT WE NEED TO BE THINKING ABOUT
WHAT KIND OF SECURITY GUARANTEE
WE AND OUR NATO ALLIES WOULD
PROVIDE FOR UKRAINE BECAUSE TO
MAKE A NEGOTIATED RESOLUTION
DURABLE AND TO GIVE CONFIDENCE
TO OUTSIDE INVESTORS AND TO
WHATEVER MARSHAL PLAN KIND OF
SUPPORT WILL BE PROVIDED, THERE
WILL NEED TO BE AN IRONCLAD
SECURITY AGREEMENT FOR UKRAINE
THIS TIME, NOTING THAT IN THE
MAST WE'VE BEEN RELUCTANT
BECAUSE WE WERE CONCERNED ABOUT
PUTIN'S SENTIMENTS ON NATO
EXPANSION.
WELL, THAT DID NOT WORK OUT.
WE SHOULD BE VERY BLUNT WITH HIM
ABOUT THAT AND SAY THAT WILL NOT
BE THE CASE THIS TIME.
WE WILL PROVIDE A SECURITY
GUARANTEE AND ENSURE IT